[Musique]
je m'appelle jean xavier belleti et g11
jeudi 10 juin l'académie saint-louis
depuis l'invasion
je joue au hockey depuis que j'ai 4 1 et
je suis gardien de but depuis l'âge de 7
ans dans cette présentation
je vais vous partager ma passion pour ce
sport je vous présenterai une idole
vous comprendrez alors que le lien qui
nous unit et notre détermination pour
notre sport favori le hope
aujourd'hui je viens vous montrer que
tout est possible mais cela n'arrive pas
par magie
selon mon expérience il faut croire en
ses rêves être déterminée travailler
fort être entouré de personnes qui nous
supportent et avoir une personne qu'ils
inspirent jonathan marchessault est un
jeune joie dans la nouvelle équipe
les golden hat de las vegas notre lien
c'est la détermination pour notre sport
faveur à mes débuts
la plupart des jeunes joueurs voulaient
aller conter début mais moi mon objectif
c'était de retourner le plus vite
possible pour arrêter landel à l'âge de
7 ans je devais faire un choix un choix
de position et voici ce que j'ai dit
pour convaincre mais pas un papa maman
je sais ce que je veux je suis assez
grand et au lieu de retourner le plus
vite possible
je vais être dans les bus vous devinez
que mes deux premières années n'ont pas
été si facile que ça je me suis retrouvé
dans les niveaux le plus élevé seule
j'ai vécu beaucoup de défaites
j telle est sa maman je vous explique
je voyais que des personnes dans mon
entourage ne croyez pas en moi en mes
capacités et je voulais leur prouver
qu'ils avaient tort
de plus je me suis aperçu que mon corps
n'était pas prêt non plus à ce
changement
donc j'ai persévéré dans les exercices à
la maison j'ai travaillé sur moi et avec
ma détermination mon travail le spa de
mes coéquipiers de ma famille avec leur
amour leur franchise et leur confiance
en moi j'ai atteint un niveau plus élevé
voici le français notre école les
mendier ce dont je viens de vous parler
ça on va plus vite mais ensemble on va
plus loin
plusieurs personnes nazisme et c'est la
france vous me décrire
john mais ce piratage a mélangé
carrément dit n'avoir jamais fait de
haut calibre en tant que je rejoins
jamais avoir été repêché mais invité par
les blue jackets de columbus en 2012
malheureusement ils ne l'ont pas gardé
dommage ils ne savent pas ce qu'il
manque aujourd'hui
il a été changé trois fois avant
d'atterrir dans les gaules mais cette
année il se retrouve parmi les 20
premiers marqueurs de son équipe et les
vrais premiers marqueurs de la ligue à
cause des doigts des meilleurs gardiens
de but marc-andré fleury et l'an dernier
il a fait tout autant de but que comique
des villes un des meilleurs joueurs
actuellement dans les lignes nationales
il m'a dit que l'espace soit sa famille
a été et est encore très important pour
lui rappelez vous il faut croire en ses
rêves être déterminée travailler fort
être entouré de personnes qui le
supportent et avoir une personne qui
nous inspire en conclusion j'espère que
mon expérience doigt convaincue que tout
est possible
et maintenant c'est à vous de quoi en
vous avant de vous laisser
voici un petit exemple que j'ai beaucoup
travaillé
[Applaudissements]